following breaking news at five o'clock
an active situation just north of
downtown Las Vegas a shooting has left
three people hurt and caused two nearby
schools to go on a hard lockdown we
thank you for joining us at five I'm
Denise Valdez and I'm Brian Loftus Metro
Police say the first calls came in about
1 30 this afternoon after a dispute
between neighbors it's all happened near
MLK and Lake Mead boulevards that's
where we find Madison Kimber with the
latest on what we've been hearing is a
pretty active situation there Madison
yes police activity here continues on
8th Street in Owens where those are the
nearby intersections take a look behind
me where you can see police assessing
the situation around 1 30 police say
there was a fight between Neighbors in
that fight three adults were shot we're
told those injuries are
non-life-threatening the school nearby
Matt Kelly Elementary School was placed
on a hard lockdown that has since been
lifted so parents were able to pick up
their kids safely
anytime that an elementary school or for
that matter any school is within close
proximity to a violent event as a as a
uh as a practice uh in coordination with
school police that school is placed in a
hard lockdown uh to ensure that uh the
safety of the children
[Music]
we are told that all the people involved
in this fight-turned shooting are in
police custody now Doolittle Avenue
remains blocked off as you can see but
the major roadways here H and Owen that
remains open Major roadways are free to
drive through reporting live Madison
Kimbrough 8 News Now